the success or failure of a bipartisan
fix for Obamacare insurance markets
could hinge on the White House the
president seemed to endorse a temporary
plan from senators Lamar Alexander and
patty Murray yesterday but then he
appeared to turn away from the deal
hours later the president is cutting off
Obamacare subsidies to health insurers
the Congressional Budget Office
estimates that could move and raise
premiums by 20 percent next year Nancy
Cordes on Capitol Hill Nancy good
morning good morning this deal is
primarily aimed at reinstating those
payments and preventing a market
upheaval it is also significant because
it's the first time in seven years that
Democratic and Republican leaders have
cut a deal that can be viewed as fixing
parts of Obamacare I'm grateful to the
president for purging me on two
occasions and phone calls to try to get
a bipartisan agreement with Senator
Murray the Republican chair of the
Senate Health Committee and his
Democratic counterpart announced that
their plan would reduce premiums on the
individual market and prevent millions
from losing coverage chairman Alexander
and I were able to find common ground on
a number of steps to stabilize the
markets their plan would provide 106
million dollars to promote Obamacare
enrollment something the White House
recently announced would be slashed the
plan would also reinstate subsidies for
insurance companies for two years
lowering the cost of coverage President
Trump announced last week he would no
longer authorize those payments that
money is going to insurance companies to
lift up their stock price and that's not
what I'm about but in the Rose Garden
yesterday mr. Trump seemed to endorse
the bipartisan deal
Lamar has been working very very hard
with the Democratic his colleagues on
the other side and patty Murray is one
of them in particular and they're coming
up and they're fairly close to a
short-term solution hours later in a
speech at the Heritage Foundation the
president seemed to change his June I
continued to believe Congress must find
a solution to the Obamacare mess instead
of providing bailouts to insurance
companies last night the president
tweeted
increase in Obamacare premiums is the
fault of the Democrats for giving us a
product that never had a chance of
working
some Republicans will argue that this
deal simply props up Obamacare a law
that many of them believe is destined to
fail but they have also been unable so
far to pass a replacement so for now
Gail there are millions of people who
rely on the stability of these
individual insurance markets Nancy thank
you